بيان مقتضب صدر من موسكو بعد اجتماع مجلس
الامن القومي الاجتماع دوري تراسه
فلاديمير بوتين والبحث تناول التجهيزات
والتحضيرات لاحياء عيد النصر على النازيه
في التاسع من ايار مايو الحالي يعكس
البيان الرسمي سياسه موسكو في التعامل مع
استراتيجياتها العسكريه والامنيه لا تعلن
عن الكثير بشكل مباشر وتفسح المجال
لتحركات ميدانيه تستعرض من خلالها بعضا
مما تخطط له الاجتماع اتى ساعه بعد اندلاع
حريق في منشاه الى سكين نفطيه غرب مدينه
كرسنو دار الروسيه نتيجه هجوم بمسيره
اوكرانيه بحسب الاعلام الروسي وهو الهجوم
الثاني على نفس المنشاه خلال 24 ساعه
كثرت التحليلات حول الرد الروسي المحتمل
او المتوقع لا سيما بعد محاوله استهداف
الكريم
نفذتها وخططت لها الولايات المتحده والغرب
بحسب اتهامات مسؤولينروس
من الواضح انه كان عملا عدائيا ومن الواضح
تماما ان ارهابيين كييف لم يكن بامكانهم
ارتكابه دون علم اسيادهم لن نرد بالحديث
عما اذا كان ذلك يستدعي ردا ام لا بل سنرد
بخطوات محدده وملموسه واود ان اكرر مره
اخرى ان لدينا كثيرا من الصبر
سترد روسيا اذا على الهجمات رغم توصل
اوكرانيا من مسؤوليتها عن المسيره فوق
الكرملين لكن السؤال يبقى كيف واين سيكون
الرد الروسي
خطوره هذه التساؤلات دفعت دولا عده الى
التحذير من نشوب نزاع مسلح مفتوح
نزاع يقول مسؤولون روس ان الولايات
المتحده لن تبقى بمعزل عنه
المؤشرات حتى الان ترجح ان الرد الروسي لا
يكون بالضروره مماثلا للهجمات الاوكرانيه
لكنه لن يتجاوز في الغالب سياق الردود
التقليديه